and now I'd like to present the winner
of last year's award for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role
mr. gig young
[Music]
thank you I know how it feels to be a
nominee and sit out there waiting for
your name to be called or to sit out
there waiting for your name not to be
called I've been on both sides so let's
get on with it the nominees for the best
performance by an actress in a
supporting role are Helen Hayes in
Airport Maureen Stapleton in airports
Lee grant in the Landlord Karen black
five Easy Pieces Sally Kellerman in mesh
and now if you'll give me that most
important line below please we'll all
faint together you may smile the winner
is Helen Hayes miss Rosalind Russell
will accept the Oscar on behalf of miss
Helen Hayes
[Music]
well on behalf of dear Helen who was
first lady of the theater and certainly
first tonight in most of our hearts I
know that she would want me to thank
George Seaton who directed her in the
film and her beloved friend and that
great and wonderful producer mr. Ross
hunter who produced the film thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]